john mulaney has that whole bit about
the voice that you get when someone
knocks on the the bathroom door he's
like all of a sudden become like a
carnival
someone's in here
absolutely yeah that's definitely a
thing i don't know that i have a
recording voice
i hate hearing my own voice through
recordings though is that a thing that
you
you usually would have doing via it just
always sounds different batman was a
real uh was a real eye-opener because i
was like man my voice is so deep
and then i listen back to him like
i barely hit puberty because then you
hear like kevin conroy are you here like
titus i mean that's a level of depth
that no one else could achieve like
that's like but his talking voice like
his i i saw him a couple weeks ago in
florida and like just his natural
speaking voice is just
i have the toast where is the jam it's
just it's just butter it's just woof
so good
so good
were you eating breakfast
i was eating breakfast with i was eating
breakfast with kevin conroy uh that's
nice i like your bars
it's a nice setup for us here it's a
nice setup that is a
conversation-leading shirt
all right go for it we can talk about it
it wasn't even a segway it was more like
just
jamming like this thing and wedging it
open but just an aggressive segway so
troy aggressiveness the passive
aggression of this flight let's talk
about your first sexual encounter yeah
what
love speaking of toast
all right it was all three of those
things all three of those things
what do you want to know we avoided
discussion
kind of
uh well we talked about the troy baker
episode barely though like we danced
who directed the episode you did troy
david up and coming guys
it's a really fun story so
uh right at the i mean just the the
heart of kovitz this was uh may of last
year i believe is when we that's like
the final boss at the end of resident
evil 7 it's my favorite documentary
about filmmaking the heart of covid into
the heart of covid
that's a great road do i have that
behind me oh look little grant kirkhope
little grant cup it's banjo a guy
uh we so right when you know we had
realized that this thing wasn't going
away and it started shutting down
productions um there's this thing that
came across the wire to my agent it was
like hey uh
would you like to audition for this and
i was like eh it's on camera
they wanted it on you know like for me
to film myself because they weren't
actually going in and having meetings
and i was like that's just really
awkward i don't want to do that and a
lot of times i'll try to skate around
that and say i'll be open to a
conversation with the creative director
or the producers or whatever but i just
i don't want to throw something out into
the void that's completely wrong so if
we can have an informed conversation
then i can do something that maybe could
be a little bit more helpful question
did they tell you for whom or what you
were auditioning
they said that um i'd have to look back
and i think it was blatant that it was
for love death and robots um and i think
after i did my first
thing no actually i think from the very
beginning is like david fincher will be
directing so i was like all right so
that was that was a bait for sure but
tim miller and i have known each other
for
for a long time and i was like i love
that dude um and i didn't realize how
incredible of a director and a writer uh
and a producer he is like i just i've
known him from blur and they did all the
you know game trailers for call of duty
and everything back in the day
um
he's a whole separate conversation but
that man is incredible um and i have a
tremendous tremendous amount of respect
for him
uh so
i i do the audition and it was a little
bit of a contentious one
just because of the nature of the
process of doing on camera stuff and
even though it's something that will be
animated but long story short
uh we
fincher says i want to see you so he was
like i want to meet with you in person
so i drove to a to a lot and there was
all these covert protocol plays and you
know
things in place and everyone was super
weird we did it outside under a tent
and we just instantly clicked and i
found out later
that as i was so you think because you
know you were 20 feet apart
he's smiling so we started shooting in
june okay turns out that was adventure
different dude uh but he was cool
because like at the very end as i was
leaving uh the the casting director was
like i want you to know i think it's
important that you know this um as you
were losing he just kind of watched you
go and it was like damn i love that dude
i was like well that's a good sign so we
got to work together
and my literally the first day of
shooting uh shows up he gathers cast and
crew together and he goes good morning
everyone i promise you by the end of the
day you will be tired
so will i
i just ask that you keep up with me and
i was like oh captain my captain let's
go
i was ready and which fits the script as
well in fact it's true
i at the end of it um
about halfway through we would eat lunch
together and stuff
you basically you had to throw the
actors down into the pit i'm trying to
work out these little things
i don't know which ones which i think
was just playing himself on the show the
challenge of it was was like inherent
because all you know this was the first
shoot back during covet so this was like
how are we navigating this and they're
like just let you know there's now a
flow of traffic if you want anything
normally if like actors wander around
set when they're not shooting they'll go
to the craft services table and they'll
pick up some kind of
you know uh snack or water whatever we
had to text somebody they would get it
for us wow we had bins that sounds great
it's
pretty smart he was like yeah i do that
is that not how you order please give me
the coffee but it was it was weird it
was a weird thing it was like how do we
how are we going to do this but it
actually offered a lot of hope that we
could
find a way through and it actually
specifically with me working in games
offered a lot of hope because i was like
i know people that literally were like i
just got the break that i've been
waiting for on the show i'm going up to
canada and then a week later like never
mind i'm coming back and i'm unemployed
and so there was a glimmer of hope that
these people who
typically work in you know either games
or animation who are constantly the tip
of the spear in the vanguard trying to
find new ways to utilize technology or
work around problems would definitely be
the one that brought the entire industry
of shooting back to work
um and so we we would um
lunch was like the only time where you
could only have two people at a table
they would sit apart but but fincher and
i would would take lunch together a lot
and he was editing mink at the same time
he was like you want to see a rough cut
it's like hell yeah let me see this and
we just got into this great
conversations
and i finally got it how long was this
shoot again about two weeks
it's crazy yeah uh it was i remember so
i i remember like because obviously
everyone watching this will probably
guess that we have mdh conversations
before and after the bit which we put
out and like i remember the the time you
were doing recording that we have we
never actually signed an nda um when you
when you were
um when you were when you were working
with him like you it was so wonderful to
see like you were just so
visibly just creatively fulfilled like
it was just a there was an aura about
you that was really cool he um i didn't
know what to think because you know you
hear stories about people and especially
anyone of that level of notoriety and
success you you don't get to that
mountain uh to the top of that mountain
i would have just only asked him about
alien
i oh
it would have been that guy
we i'm trying to work out i've got a
book on fincher in the next room and the
urge to go and grab it just to bring
back directly behind you i don't believe
you i don't think you have it yeah i
don't think actually those are the only
books you have that's a lot
some of those books look like dinosaurs
a lot of them are about those oh there
is a dinosaur
well there goes the spoiler alert
spoiler alert yeah
i'm sure reading a lot about dinosaurs
at the moment i finally ate one of those
languages
i asked him i was like it's like i think
i've i think i've figured you out uh i
said because you have all these voices
and coming at you from either actors or
you know producers or writers or
whomever
and i said you
you could be the person who's like yeah
i think i'm going to let my career stand
on its own merit and go [ __ ] off and he
listens to people he goes it's creative
darwinism you know i i i'm open to any
best best idea wins i don't care
and i said the reason why you like to do
so many takes is he goes because they'll
let if they let me shoot i just want to
shoot just let me shoot i'll shoot all
day he's like i just love it so much so
the passion i was like man that's truly
someone who has who's found a way to
um
professionalize their passion in just a
very very cool way but he's do you have
a sense from that just again jumping on
that point before you move to the next
one sure do you how do you
do you get a sense of how someone like
that
can
balance that with the diminishing
returns that eventually start to appear
when you're like
okay take 17
we're just it will never get better from
this point forward there's just no way
it could get better
like i don't think he feels that way i
think that he the cast must start to
feel that way sure
and there's a lot of stuff where where
i could see him doing it was like i need
to i'm going to do this because i need
to break down your idea you came in full
and i need you to come in empty
and
um
trying to skirt around something there's
there's a shoot that i did where
we were in the middle of the scene
and the camera camera was not
necessarily looking at me but i was
definitely could be within frame and the
dp came up out of nowhere while we were
shooting
grabbed him by the shoulders and started
moving me and i it was it was jarring
but i realized what he was doing was he
was positioning me
so that shoulder yeah he was like
camera's looking
down here
but he just kept moving me and i had one
of two choices i could fight against it
or i could just go with it and i just
wherever he wanted to move me he moved
me
and we cut
and the the camera op that was down
there he was like cut he goes
jesus christ that was the most
terrifying thing i've ever seen he goes
because your shadows were just playing
all over her face
and i was like you saw that he was like
he goes i'm sorry i just i i didn't want
to get in there and say anything
but i just i saw this opportunity i was
like whatever you want to do and it's
those moments where it's like the
natural tendency within me can be to
push back or be afraid or be
uncomfortable and say you don't get the
you don't get to do that to me or you
know i want to have some agency in this
and sometimes you just [ __ ] let go i
think a certain musical number with
merle dandridge uh
suggests a willingness to just roll with
whatever
uh
yeah
yeah i mean
i i i actually i always have had a hard
time expecting that that was a real
thing
that he has pants on right now
eerie very was a ghost to my house yeah
seriously
that's just a banjo uh you know like
human form yeah exactly
touched the rune or whatever there's
actually a director of photography
grabbing him
if you can i don't know how much like
this stuff you're not allowed to talk
about but in terms of like filming
process are we is it that they're
filming this is it like the full mocap
suits face cameras it's that it's that
that's set up yeah we did four minutes
and they typically yeah what's funny i
really want this uh is he in the mocap
gear as well yes
he's not actually there he's just he's
he's vote captain
so we got to the point to where um
because of how coveted protocols were
we were kind of having to
go in for coverage on face
so that meant that only one person or
maybe two people at a time were actually
wearing the full camera rig um as covert
protocols became more and more
standardized and we were starting able
to have it be a safer place we could
loosen up on that and so face cams
became no problem
but specifically for that it was like we
can do this with two people and
everybody else if you don't have to have
you know uh
your mask off keep your mask on so
everyone you know there's a big cast
there's like 12 to 15 people
um and they had a huge set build the the
thing where i kind of come down if you
watch the episode i come down into the
hold of the ship that was a staircase
that they actually built oh wow i was
gonna ask because the shot where you're
running towards the camera how are you
doing otherwise yeah i did i did all
that i was like
um
uh
please thank you yeah
troy over here troy um
mine's a much less intellectual question
yeah wha what giant crap what do they do
like is that is that a problem that was
me that was me a lot so there was the
main thing is that he had the puppet
that he was kind of the meat puppet that
he was talking through uh and so that
person was on set
um so i had that's interesting yeah so
he was there kind of being the
slowly decomposing body
talking to me um but there was no there
was always like remember behind him
is was that a person or was that like a
a prop a person as an actual person
actual actor
uh and then
i believe i want to give credit to him
fred tata short came in and actually
uh was the was the final voice because
you get fred tata sure to do
hold your hand up mike it might focus
like this usually doing this help there
you go there we go oh there you go there
you go that's that's why we have
seasoned professionals
did you know what it would look like
ahead of time we had some concept art uh
because it is based upon a short story
um i loved it i thought it was so well
done the story's brilliant like the yeah
the morality questions like it was i
just loved it i thought it was fantastic
one of the best episodes of that show
i've ever seen something that i had to
give absolute credit to fincher for um
we got to the point where we were just
running out of time because we we had to
go in and get coverage for all these
little pieces and it came to the point
to where
uh
either everybody was gonna have to stay
late like a day
uh
or i would shoot my coverage by myself
and i said i'll go late you can cut
everybody else home and he goes really
he's like do you have any doubts he goes
nope i think he can do it i was like
okay
so it ended up show up with a sleeping
bag that day hey well what they ended up
doing is like we need to shoot a bunch
of like just stuff in here so we're
going to move
fincher you and troy are going to go
into this control room
different part of the studio we're going
to give the mocap stage to everybody
else and it ended up just being david
and i with me in the mocap helmet
and like the con not even the recording
booth but actually just like the control
room of the studio
working through all the scenes
and
i think those were the ones
every one of my scenes i think came from
there
like really yeah that was gonna be my
question of if it's weird working on an
ensemble piece where you don't have
because i assumed because the covert
stuff you wouldn't have all of the
ensemble at all times when you're
shooting like on the set everybody would
have been more removed right oh everyone
everyone was there around you everybody
was there and so like when there was
that one they were hitting the numbers
which was 2020. that's a covered
production and it was always everybody
there they just appreciate it but in
that situation
like you literally need that for the
recording i wondered if they'd cut
corners or something but it sounds like
fair play yeah no good that's why they
they were saying we could have two
people with with masks off but like
during rehearsal and everything a lot of
times that's still the case now like
there's shoots that i'm doing where
they're like if you if we aren't rolling
masks are on so yeah rahul is also still
doing that it's it's pretty nuts like
the some of the covered protocols uh he
currently has to get tested every day
yeah we get tested every day yeah um
and if somebody gets covered
then they're executed yeah basically
they're they do they see the red letter
i probably can't see the red light
immediately
red light a media thing sorry apologies
i just talked to you no you're okay i
realized i was gonna say something
probably that
yeah yeah yeah it's gonna be something
to share
the red did you see before you share
that austin the red light media thing
where they've started noticing that like
actors sometimes you can see like the
indentations of masks
in stuff because obviously you're uh
yeah so that's now a thing where you
start
the intersection of 4k wow it's kind of
that thing
and you wonder if that we're nearly a
point where they're gonna start like cg
that out of shots like the henry cavill
mustache
yeah
yeah yeah like lower stakes that's so
nuts because it'll be like such a
reflection of when it was shot if this
ever ends i don't i don't have faith
anymore i think we may be ends forever
at this point
the arc of this podcast
you know when the tv show like subtly
alludes to like world events happening
in the background this podcast has we've
not said the word even no we have okay
we have just not much what words
nothing something's happening
i know something's happening
oh austin what did you have austin i
well i was just i was just uh being
annoying but i did have another question
um i remember you please raise your hand
i like this episode
it's a good episode
[Laughter]
uh austin austin wintry wintry
productions hi yeah um
sorry spotify listeners who missed the
amazing coup de grace pulled off
um
my
you as mike
said
you definitely were on cloud nine and
you said something like
it was you know it was like a it was
like a college education in two weeks um
and
what
i just i just have a [ __ ] spotify
don't tell the spotify listeners this is
the fun the visual medium
i'm getting i'm getting the joaquin
phoenix uh
uh you know
but um
i'm curious because that was a deep cut
right there that was a long walk
i had to go for i was like oh seriously
i don't know what that's a reference to
gladiator oh
yes that was my favorite movie when i
was a kid
i don't i don't know what that says
about me that's a fun caveat yeah i
don't know what that says about me it's
a travel movie it still holds up it was
my favorite movie for a very long time
not today very closely competing
like he's made some good movies since
then but i don't think he's topped that
one kingdom of heaven director's cut
maybe
whoa
i've heard that i said that i've heard
the director's cut
i like the movie i like kingdom of
heaven
would you would you like an hour and a
half more of that movie
no but is it truly better than gladiator
is gladiator is just flawless
very concise i hardly agree braveheart
is a flawless movie okay
uh i think ghostbusters is a perfect
movie
ghostbusters is a perfect movie yeah we
could sit here and have a austin i'm not
forgetting you austin i'm dying
a perfect song you're gonna laugh at
this
an example of it that the best example
is hey jude perfect song
i'm talking about the recording of it
the the the execution of it everything
right
perfect song
i would also say
brian adams have you ever really loved a
woman is a perfect song you don't have
to like the song but it is a it sets out
to do exactly what it wants to do
perfectly i almost feel like a lot of
songs could be considered perfect a lot
more than other
mediums probably right
but breakfast movie there's probably a
lot more songs than
other entrepreneurs
i'm just enjoying watching like
what did how do you define perfection
like movies according to you know for me
he's often set out to do what they
intended i think my definition of
perfection would be austin for the
suggestion
yeah i feel i feel there's an
interesting this is like basically
we're basically in the boba fett
you know like let's just pause this show
and do mandalorian for a few episodes
like we'll come back to my question
sometime yeah but my favorite thing
about it is that you don't get annoyed
by it we don't get annoyed by it but the
audience always does the audience is
always like just let austin finish so
we're trolling man he asked the question
please
i know all right it's true um
i was curious
given how much time you've spent
doing
mo uh performance capture yeah
you described it like you learned a lot
and i'm curious if there was anything
specific that you did that you hadn't
ever done
like to that like it because i can see
learning a lot be
his directorial style was just totally
different from others and you learned a
lot about how to interact with actors or
like i can see a lot of things along
that wavelength but also just the thing
and i'd love to hear about that but it's
a separate thing from
the actual
techniques of capturing a performance
inherent to performance capture did he
use it in a way that's just novel
to
the
many hours you've spent doing it the way
you're used to there's something that's
worth the wait yes for sure there's
something can we edit the episode to
make it even later in the episode the
star of the episode before you answer
troy mike i have to tell you the amount
that you are moving your mic is going to
make the levels a nightmare
you keep doing it it's gonna it's gonna
be another compressor on there sometimes
mike
likes two minutes into the episode goes
i'm just gonna increase my gain a little
bit which means that you have to change
the way it was edited the whole time
before that it's like you remember that
episode of the office where they're
trying to hide from the camera you want
me to make a video game i'll do a good
job i've got a professional podcast
as is demonstrated although i have got a
new mic which i'm going to have in
america we might have a new mic soon if
you're not careful
yeah
your replacement is right and blind
rami yeah though he's better but we'll
call him mike just for spike mike too
he'd love that he'd love to make his
airport situation's a lot easier i think
yeah no [ __ ] 100 would speed up you've
been randomly selected uh these people
please
no i've never heard of mike johnson
well i can yeah i can talk about what i
like
to capture during the process for sure
troy would you like to answer the
question yeah i love that we also
delayed your answering austin's delight
it's kind of now a bit and i inserted
another question before
you should no it's time you should i'm
gonna just move my mind carry on i do
also want to talk about uh no
um we
there's a there's a lost art i think
that sometimes because the
advent of the technology allowed us to
be able to shoot things that before like
if you go back and watch the the
the early precursors of this like with
beowulf specifically
um
uh what's the cinematic masterpiece
zebekus yeah zemeckis
there's a there's a shot where it's the
kind of coming out and and he's there on
the bow of the ship and he was like they
shot that he goes we did that in 22
minutes this would have taken me a week
to do
to do the build to do the camera setups
to do all that everything was like
because we just did that in twenty's
like this is incredible
and i actually find it very inspiring
that that something
that episode is so good and that it was
made in two weeks like yes more than
that when you include the writing and
the it's still based on a short story
and all that but being able to make
something that good in two weeks a lot
of talented people
it's months and months of animation for
sure that's the thing to capture the
core performance but i remember watching
it because we went to a a screening of
it with uh tim miller and and um
and fincher and also i'm
blanking on her name right now but also
the showrunner the supervising uh
animation director she's incredible uh i
also loved the animation the art was so
cool dude i mean
like yeah right along the lines of
realistic but super stylized kind of
edging towards like brink if you
remember brink that yeah yeah really
elongated kind of almost french comic
book i want to feel i want to see how
ken levine feels about it because it
felt very levine-esque to me just in the
in the style of it um but if you haven't
watched jabarro that one is truly
exceptional as well it's the very last
episode
um it is a poem it is it is just
absolutely beautiful and it seemed to me
that they hired
dancers to play that's it
i'll check it out there's two actors um
and we could get another conversation
about that i don't know there were any
other episodes i just watched yours i
actually only watch uh or play anything
that features troy baker so i mean
that doesn't limit things
i thought that one was cute
yeah you had a living mini dead i was
howling with laughter just the way that
everything starts off is that the
stop-motion one i've heard about that
yes
it's very it's very cute but i remember
i saw someone wrote like this is the
best five minutes ever made or something
i was like well
you know i don't know that that kind of
that set it up probably on the internet
yeah i know exactly but it was you can't
say that
it was to me to me that your episode and
and jabarro are
staunchly uh head and shoulders um i did
i did quite like um did you end up
watching the first episode austin first
i watched them all yeah i watched it i
really didn't like the first episode
it's it's
was there a pig in there it was very
very on the nose it was it was it was
too on the nose i was like
we know what you're doing yeah that's
the thing it played its hand and then it
and then it and then it just
continuously played that hand over but
it's also it was a hand that a million
other people have already played it was
like yeah okay i agree it's something
that's i feel is important to uh set the
tone of the show
to where like even though it's
anthological uh
yeah how they would choose what goes
like
i think the first series was like it was
an interesting gimmick that i think the
first series on netflix was random it
was different in different countries was
it really it was in countries i know it
was different in different places i
think second and third they've kind of
standardized but i remember that first
one because people were like oh i loved
the first episode the first episode was
very similar to the first episode of
this to where it was
funny you know dark humor robot
going through it like that first opening
shot people were like that's the last of
us like they literally did the crane up
shot walking down the desolution dark
human robot is a great genre
yeah what is that funny dark humor robot
is what you said funny document robot
of that show yeah
affecting like every now and again
they'll have one that's really like i
mean jabarro is very like you said it's
a poem and it's and it's got this kind
of
beautiful kind of dark beauty but every
now and again there's one that's that's
really
drowned giant if you haven't watched
that before yeah previous one that's tim
miller's tim miller directed that one
and it is it surprised me because he's
just
he's touching yeah
and without being too sentimental but
it's just like it really is is um it
doesn't rely on sentiment to to do its
and there's stuff from previous volumes
go back and watch um they're just really
really clever and man especially blur
studios i can't say enough about
um
how
incredibly talented those people are and
the level of fidelity that they got
where pam was sitting there just
elbowing she's like that's real like
it's not she's like that's real like
it's not the thing that was so awesome
about jabarro from an animation
standpoint was that it would be super
photo realistic in certain ways but then
like the way they moved the sword was
very animated and it was like there's
clear choices being made about what to
be realistic and what not to be
they do that in anime all the time for
comedy and i love it it's you know it's
not that it looks realistic it's anime
but then they cut to like extremely 2d
just little dots for eyes like the jokes
i've always really loved that that style
and one punch man does an incredible job
of it that show's so funny yeah and it
like a lot of that is just like shifting
animation like it shifts in fights it
gets really dirty like it's it's very
cool to watch
they do the same thing and like teen
titans go and and there's a lot of shows
that are like kids shows uh teenage
mutant ninja turtles spongebob doing the
opposite right oh yeah where it gets
really really gross yeah yeah well
that's like the written stuff they have
to learn how to do that much like troy
had to learn from david fincher on the
set of his new episode i forgot what
the
question austin even asked was it so i
here's what i would say uh i guess i
didn't really get an answer
[Laughter]
but here's the thing what is an answer
really
let's get into that
what is true um what is true i remember
once uh when i was uh my first thing
that i ever did uh was a pilot for abc
that never got picked up and i got a
chance to meet uh of all people lou
diamond phillips i know i've never heard
this story before
oh man you had me i was like i was like
for two thirds of that i was i was so
ready to follow you down that road
and then i was like walked outside i was
like how do i get his attention and uh i
just stopped smoking at that time and
people were like [ __ ] fast forward um
they could probably get it to the second
when i'm done with the story too i
probably told so many times
um
there's many things that i learned from
venture um one of them is i mean that
man has has just looked down the
viewfinder of a camera for so long he
knows it so intimately well
that
i remember specifically one i'm backing
up off the i come running down the
stairs and then i you know slammed down
and then i come backing off and he was
like i need you to look back over your
shoulder to see what's up can i get out
this way and come here and he was like
put your right hand it was like playing
twisters like put your right hand here
drop your left foot now brace yourself
with your left arm
don't turn your body look over your
shoulder there
and it was like that's how you look
great i was like i know the frame and
again
i i really have allowed myself to get
kind of too wrapped up it's like hey i
know what i'm doing at this point i need
you to just stop being so prescriptive
and so specific and just let me play
with it let me see what happens
and then
when i allow myself to just really
submit myself to somebody else's process
i'm like damn first of all i didn't know
i could do that
secondly
he would teach me he's like here's why
here's the framing that you're getting
now you've got this you know straight
line of your jaw it doesn't mash into
your neck it actually and i was like
damn you really know what you're talking
about so i i learned that
but
is it just is a way to summarize that
that it was just
more laser precise than
yeah he would he would point to
spots on the matte box and go look here
now look here look here look here from
my eyeliner goes back to your this
look here and that's exact on this lens
with this distance for this effect i
want you to look here but he's still
going to get caught looking sometimes he
was like having that kind of expertise
is just it's just the best and when you
get to be around them and see it and
learn from it
like it's just the best but just to even
see him making
music video experience coming through
right a lot of kind of that original
kind of uh what's the name of the group
he was with that did all the music
videos not collective or oh i know
you're talking about um
yeah collective sounds right though
um it's something like that but yeah
that that kind of that kind of
specificity feels very much like i have
to shoot
you know
a bunch of shots in two days with
someone who is not an actor but can sing
well you know it's like it's that kind
of
specificity that's kind of carried
through and i think it's it's because he
was just like i'm open to anything you
have to say you have a better idea my rm
is really really strong so if your
argument is better than mine i will
happily yield to it but if it's not
stand you witness that did anybody go
hey what do you think of this my
favorite
argument my favorite moment
so
tim miller pan picks every story and he
is the most voracious reader i've ever
met he is
he he goes i burn through kindles
because i just break them he won't read
actual books he was like because i can't
carry that many with me and he will just
burn through books and he and fincher
have known each other for a very long
time
so
tim is just a very unassuming dude he
just he's always barefoot he wears jeans
same t-shirt and he'll just kind of walk
he looks like dana white he looks like a
wrestler he's got cool tattoos sleeves
on both arms and he just kind of will
walk around the perimeter of the volume
and for the most part he kind of stayed
out of the way he was there to be a
producer but just kind of like it's
david fincher's show just let him run it
and but he definitely had specific ideas
of what he wanted and why he chose this
story and how he's kind of maybe getting
away from the source material a little
bit
and so finally
day seven or whatever day six
he goes um
uh fencer was just choosing one thing
he's like dad you guys can just kind of
come through here and he he was kind of
just maybe glossing over a beat that
fencer thought or tim thought and he
goes
david i i really appreciate what you're
doing but i just kind of disagree and
goes what he goes well based upon you
know the original short story what he's
talking about here in nautical terms
what would actually be happening is this
and you wouldn't actually do that they
would make sure that they would want him
and he just starts going into a very
very
exhaustive incredibly cogent
you know argument full of salient points
to support like based upon this not only
the source material the tone that we're
going for but also from these are
nautical people and they would not be
doing this they would absolutely make
sure that they would go to this first
before doing that and fincher goes
yeah chicks dig that ready yet
and you saw tim just go [ __ ]
oh but it was just and there was there
was such a great fraternity and like
without being bros it was just
friendship and he was like well that's
you that's right that's you
really rude if you want like i mean
the air the the air was cut by his wit
in that just the timing of yeah chicks
dig that ready yet here we go
but what i what i what i feel what is
another lesson that i learned from him
to finally answer your question austin
and now we cue the music and we go hi
everybody i'm alana pierce
[Laughter]
playing over the credits
um is that with the advent of all this
technology uh boy you guys didn't know
you're gonna get a troy baker episode
did you [ __ ] um
you guys you know please put the very
top of those by the way it's a troy
episode if you guys want to tune out now
go for it
um
a very troy episode is the name
we have lost kind of the the foundation
of what it's based upon
um hey we don't have to actually have
our camera here on the day so let's just
not worry about camera let's just you
know really focus on how the actors feel
about this and we don't have any really
lighting so we can think about that
later but we never think about where the
light source is coming from and so i've
seen a lot of games specifically
that oh [ __ ] the reason why we chose
this shot was because something organic
happened on the set or an actor did
something or the way that the lens
happened to look in this space
um and so getting away from that but a
very critical thing that i saw
not only on this shoot but also on
another shoot
was coverage
and because we shoot
games as a you know each scene is is a
play right so we're shooting that mosque
is the biggest differences between
games for mocap and something like this
for mocap or if there are major
differences there's
i can't speak to how everybody else
worked because i think different
directors are going to work different
ways uh some people are very familiar
with performance capture as a medium and
as a process and so they will kind of
lean more into those things venture was
like i don't know man i don't know what
this is i'm just gonna i'm give me a
camera a night now i know how to shoot
that's performance capture that's the
first one
he's very tech savvy he's been like yeah
but he's he's not a luddite
he's an analog dude like he is like you
look at mank and the way that he
actually austin you would appreciate
this he
um wanted to
record the sound in mono so he went to a
theater that was built in the 20s and
used period accurate mics
to play back the music and the sound and
record that with those mics so that it
was
authentic truly authentic at that time
just as a choice i was like that that
score i think i have it here i can kind
of pull a mic
um
because that that's you could probably
play a bit right
now that score was a huge about phase
pulling it off trent resner and atticus
ross because it's like this bernard
style 1930s sort of quasi-jazzy
melodramatic orchestra yeah kind of
sound and when they were doing the oscar
campaigns uh hold on let me see if i
have it where is your piano
don't worry about it see it
yeah he moved it over there and it's
freaking me out i don't like chase
sorry sorry i had a meeting and it was
blocking the couch all right go find
your book
so now i'm going to answer the question
and i'm going to make sure that and
more than anything that's what i learned
yeah i finally answered the question
yeah yeah yeah thank you for sharing
that with us i love how you were you
were
four seconds away from from answering it
definitively that's a really interesting
answer
look at that oh nice see yeah studios
would often send out uh
cds and dvds screeners for the awards
consideration for manc
they sent
handwritten
sheet music from the score holy pass
written so they they wow yeah like you
can see
um
this is uh it's a little bit
let me
turn this so you can actually i'm like
upset about you folding that because i
like look at that it's such a high value
i didn't say they're like oh please
don't fold that yeah yeah that's so cool
and so just the very fact that they
would be using handwritten scores speaks
to the mono thing as well like the the
the authenticity of how would it have
been done
um
i thought this was cool commented all
austin that people would hand write a
score i'd imagine not anymore no reason
to do that right john williams does but
as soon as he's really written the score
it he gives it to the copyists who
immediately put it in the software and
digitize it because they have to mass
produce parts for for
the whole
yeah the reason that job is called
copyist is because in the old days it
would be a room full of people crowded
around a table with one conductor score
and they're all literally like i'm
making the violin part yeah yeah exactly
illuminated texts maybe changing some
things in the margins
yeah basically i don't think people
should get married
yeah exactly
it was um
anyway i thought of all the of all the
uh
funny thing i don't think they ended up
getting nominated for this one uh but um
it may should have probably you know
done it on the computer that would yeah
exactly probably should have sent an
actual screener so a bit more helpful
pretty
i thought that was a really cool way to
promote your yeah promote your if you're
doing the awards thing at least that's a
cool way to do it you know
i i throw away the discs because i'm
like i don't have a hard format anymore
guys i know sadly i'm in the same boat
by the way serena's out for most things
in 720p
they don't even send screeners in 1080
majority hillary
relatable stuff we talked about this
here yeah here is something that is on a
platform called netflix they were
nominated for score i stand corrected
yeah they just didn't
you corrected yourself and then said i
stand corrected yeah you didn't have to
do that it's okay
whoever said that was a [ __ ] idiot
okay uh troy
presumably well no it's just like
yeah it's like
you here here's our disk oh yeah screen
up something on netflix yeah we'll go to
netflix yeah give me a code
it is trent reznor
and atticus ross still won
but they won for seoul the pixar film
that i forgot
they were double nominated uh against
themselves we could do we could do a
little john
they have they've done a wide range of
scores yeah uh kind of given that
everyone else is kind of still ripping
off their first one it's more like
interesting than everyone else i feel
like soul
everything
fits under a certain trajectory and soul
was the big outlier i don't see it as
like emblematic of a huge wide thing
although mank was
while still emotionally in the kind of
sort of darker end of the spectrum that
they tend to live in it was executed in
a way wildly outside of the kind of nine
inch nails e thing that
god he's so [ __ ] talented
so talented he is a very talented there
are some people it just annoys me you
know
anarchist also is not to be
underestimated because if you listen to
atticus
i i always i always wondered actually
how the division of labor worked because
when i heard the score to the book of
eli which was atticus by himself
i was like this is every bit is good
yeah yeah that's gary messed that up
no i love that score that's my point
like that was adequate i thought this is
every bit as good
as when they work together um maybe
trent sucks then no he doesn't i mean
maybe
yeah maybe
maybe did you see any face did you see
his poi his uh his part in uh
the foo fighters or a dave grohl's
documentary uh where he kind of did a
song with with all these different
people that went with paul mccartney uh
did one with tread wrestling that's cool
didn't they make the foo fighters make a
movie it's cool yeah right before like a
horror film i love that like i love the
a band just doing whatever the [ __ ] they
want to is just very good dude man [ __ ]
yeah that would have been right before
right he came out pretty long time right
before he died
that was that was a huge i was like wait
a minute what
that was kind of like kobe bryant level
like wait a minute no you don't die yet
you're totally fine
um yeah it sucks all right aside from
that so
uh
with the advent of all this technology i
feel like we've we've been able to
[ __ ]
robots
the
coverage specifically and being able to
um
just stay in a moment and just try
different things just just micro things
as opposed to we've shot it all
um
it's it's challenged me it's inspired me
as a director like i want to
uh even even if it's just vo um
being able to utilize some tenements of
film
that for some people who may not do a
lot of vo who know how to kind of
um manipulate their performance in a way
because they're used to this medium if
they're not
when they're normally told
we're close on you like i want to be
tight on you and so that inherently will
change their performance
so being able to utilize some of those
tenements and not throw them away just
because technology has allowed us to no
longer depend on them
can start impacting the art and the
performance
that
so i know it'll be a long time before we
get into any kind of
meet on
summerfall and stray gods yeah but it's
no secret that you are directing our
cast on that game
and
[Music]
having watched you direct like a
thousand sessions now no
it didn't occur to me that this wasn't
something you
would have always done uh this is
literally right off of that right right
off of that and the second shoot that i
did i was like we've forgotten how to do
this because there are times where
you know you'll say to the actor
this is
your arms folded here and it's not like
they're they're in a vocal booth they're
not
it's not like you need to literally fold
your arms and most of the time they
don't but
but the implications that go with that
give them what they need to work with i
would find that very helpful like super
helpful somebody's been really cool to
watch it's been really cool to watch
because this question
got answered but austin has also
directly benefited from the answer to
austin is the best uh and i use this a
lot um the best uh conducting
uh advice that you were given
from john malcheri was
uh to to hold my feet together hold your
feet together
why why yeah
uh it just has a domino effect of of
like it modifies your posture
which then
modifies
your perceived confidence
um you can't really slouch uh that's
fascinating that that is the best advice
you've received we were literally at the
poolside
restaurant at the beverly hills hotel
and he goes he goes uh he was he does he
lives in new york so he was visiting la
either to conduct i think he was doing
a nightmare before christmas at the
hollywood bowl he does a lot of danny
elfman stuff and he was like
meet me for lunch we had lunch and he
points at a table three tables over and
he goes that's where jerome robbins
arthur lawrence stephen sondheim and
leonard bernstein decided to change it
from east side story to west side story
because they were reading about gang
warfare and like turf wars in new york
city
and
and then he had just seen uh mythos um
no way and that's where i first met him
was in the lobby after mythos he came to
that show
and um
he
it might it was either that or when we
did journey live in new york i can't
remember how far back i'll say his
mythos so i can somehow be a jesus yeah
you can be a part of it yeah so that was
our first rodeo and um
so
uh anyway he yeah he i said i was like
nervous to ask we talked for like an
hour and then finally i go okay so i
have to just ask how
you feel about my conducting because i'm
always like i'm a composer conductor i'm
not a conductor composer like conducting
is an outgrowth of composing and it's
not there are a lot of conductors who
don't compose
the majority of professional conductors
aren't
at best
presumably they're conducting music that
was written they're like yeah they're
conducting stravinsky and beethoven and
yeah sure but i mean would they not also
i would just be a lot of them are
trained okay you just trained to become
a conductor a lot like even mao cherry
has a degree in composition but he
hasn't written music and like probably
oh so they all trained in composition
like alana's saying so they have no no
no that's like i think it's like it it's
not
there are people that study conducting
they get degrees in conducting that's
all they do
and but there are
a good chunk of them that
do compose music here and there but
making it as a conductor
is such an uphill climb there's so few
slots
that it's an all-time it's a full-time
gig to really have a shot at so they
just you know it's so then what do you
mean by you being a composer conductor
like do you think that because you're a
composer first and that's what you do
most of the time it changes the way you
conduct
it just means that if given finite
amount of time i will always
focus on being a better composer
first than being a better conductor i
see so you haven't been trying to
like i will yeah i will there will
always be conductors who are better than
me in other words like and that's no
composers ever
no composers yeah get out john williams
show you yeah
and uh but uh no the point is it's just
where you put your priorities you know
there's some people that are truly adept
at both leonard bernstein is one of the
rare examples of somebody who was
a truly original amazing composer just
despite the fact that he was also like
the most famous american conductor
that's but he's the only one he's the
only example you think of every other
famous conductor gustavo dudamel michael
tilson thomas none of them are known as
composers esopeka salanine was
the conductor of the la phil for many
decades and stopped in order to sound
like a medicine for diabetes
can we can we do an episode at some
point of you i've decided the show needs
to continue because i have i want to sh
we haven't had a big one really you were
you were you were just there
i'm pitching in austin i'm pitching an
austin episode i i fundamentally i don't
think we have time right now to go into
because you've all got to go back to
work but
i fundamentally don't understand what
conducting is as a layman i look at it i
don't get it it's most professions you
can look at it and you can go okay i
don't fully understand how this
profession works but i understand why
driving a bus is difficult right whereas
with conducting i i i must admit like as
the layman i look at it i see a man
wiggling the stairs
i was always like
i don't know i think that man just kind
of stands there and isn't needed like i
think that maybe helps a little bit i
don't know exactly it's like a nice
thing
yeah with absolute humility and genuine
like like honestly i want to know why
earthquakes happen i get so much more
out of watching
i am i i'd enjoy watching music more i
think if i knew the craft and what's
going on there yeah well if i may
suggest
if you ever get the opportunity to go to
a any kind of classical performance
opera
whatever not only with austin but also
with andrea pacino
yeah
holy really exclusively see performances
of the journey soundtrack i don't see
any other music in life yeah that's my
only as one should
unfortunately it's always playing
somewhere it is
also like just
i know that he's the guy that you take
to music stuff
no no he takes us uh yeah right 100 we
are his plus ones i like him he's very
cool we are the purse holders in that
situation 100
andrea is is first off he was a child
prodigy level pianist growing up who
decided to become a programmer but he
had he's a fully capable composer
and he owns a massive synth collection
did he do
the music on um he was he worked on the
order right yeah he was the he's a
co-founder he and two others are
co-founders of ready
yeah but did he like the moment too no
no he's the technical director he he's
so nuts to have that like diversity he
basically built their physics that's
that was what he did okay
and he's superb
very nice he's like a former world
champion
buff and nice yes he is the most he is
the most gentle
poetic he cried every when we did the uh
the
journey um
recording in london
every song he cried
and and just like like
was when he cried and he went to look
for a tissue and all he could find was
disinfectant wipes and he wiped his face
with it so he looked like he looked like
eyes are burning i was like i know man
what a beautiful moment
maybe we now just let him just
have it
every episode is just him by himself no
he he we what troy is also alluding to
is that after the recording session one
of the nights uh andrea saw
that the
opera
the royal opera house was doing uh
verdi's nabucco
and
and so he just bought tickets for us all
and was like we're going to the office
second row directly behind the conductor
yeah we were we were like inch we were
basically in the in the pit um
and uh yeah no i mean the orchestra you
know where they were like
we were we were i could have reached out
and tapped him on the shoulder he was
the most animated like could
yeah you heard his breathing you heard
his breathing through the whole show it
was so funny
it was yeah it was so and andrea just so
passionate
i love that that's the best way to like
in terms of like just advice to like
people watching this like
doing the going to an experience or
having experience with like someone
who's like into it like that's my i
think i've said it on the show before
like if i ever find out someone's like
obsessed with something i'll actively
like i'll find out oh you love whiskey
oh cool i'm going out drinking yes
absolutely
like a connoisseur of like a thing is
like just the best experience
rahul just bought me something having a
really pretty paint brushes i think
they're artist opus
um and he's gonna teach me how to paint
minis and i'm super excited about it
like are you only allowed to paint minis
off his head though yeah it's got to be
his head sculpt that he had 3d rendering
there's a joke there i'm going to leave
it alone
leave it alone love you roll uh well
look we can uh i'll happily walk you
through uh conducting some other time uh
and um but um
[Music]
uh
there was some what was the thread
though that uh oh it was the the just
the thing about john maucheri it just
blew my mind that that i was so nervous
to ask him for advice uh on my
conducting because he's a real conductor
he's conducted basically every orchestra
on the in the planet he was bernstein's
pick for the last 18 years of
bernstein's life where if he couldn't do
it
uh john maucher is going to be the one
to do it uh like he can he conducted uh
premieres of bernstein's original music
he was you know he's
the real the real deal um and uh he
he yeah it was exactly as troy was
saying where he just goes
stand up and like we're at the
restaurant at the in the backyard
basically of this hotel and i was like
what he goes just like treat me as the
concert master and
prepare a downbeat for me so i stood up
next to table and and stood up and he
goes now freeze and look at your feet
and he was like just slide them together
is everything else is going to take care
of itself from there because it was
crazy how your whole body just changes
from that like you can't
if you if you do if the things that i
was doing with my feet spread apart
would make me fall over physically i
wouldn't be able to hold my face my fair
lady it's brilliant it was so successful
specific thing that kind of changes yeah
i love that
something about that that's like
someone just giving you a tip like that
that
you should never think of yeah that just
affects that that's very cool that's
super sweet it was really cool
yeah it was yeah it was it was
very s unforgettable moment and like
the thing that sparked this which is
like troy telling a voice actor to fold
their arms or whatever i was saying like
as somebody who is not very good at
acting and still learning
the one of the hardest things i ever did
that didn't
go anywhere because i couldn't do it was
i had to die
and i ha i just i so they rewrote the
character to live is that what you're
saying
someone else could cost because i
couldn't do it um really yeah which is
like fair i couldn't do it i was like i
don't know how to do this i had to die
of fiery death in a car
and um
i i kept trying to do things
with my voice and i wish that somebody
like thinking about it now because one
of the first things i ever did i wish
somebody had told me to do something
physically because it never occurred to
me that i should have like been
physically pressing something or pushing
something or like exerting because i i
just tried i was just like i just it's
all emotion but it's not it like it had
to be physical but i wish yeah i wish i
had had that tip it's it's so
interesting to think about
there's which i had an anecdote about a
luminary of my industry telling me to do
something physically with my body i've
been asked
what inspector once asked me to pass him
some garlic bread that would be awesome
i want to clip that yeah just my head
just went to mike thank you for trusting
us with that they'll share your truth
yeah exactly where where on the door
that's i was gonna say i've had some
some people in the industry tell me to
do some things with my body none of them
none of them are great none of them are
great
i i would highly recommend if if uh
whether you want to direct or direct
actors or
be an actor that's better directed uh
judith weston has a great book um called
directing actors and uh
i'm still in the middle of reading it
because i jump in between
uh books all the time
but the main thing is is
to go to like you were talking about a
lot as like as far as an emotional thing
if i say we need to be angry in this
you're angry right now
what does that mean like you you may get
really quiet when you get angry and i
may be getting really really loud i get
really quiet so now we're in conflict
and first we have to agree
on what anger is
and how we demonstrate that as opposed
to
and typically whenever someone gives
what's called a result-oriented
direction it's always out of insecurity
it's because they're they're lazy
they're not willing to go the extra step
of saying is you might as well just line
read the person
the difference is is going objective
obstacle action all right so
here's what you want to do
here's what's in your way of that
do something about it and i one of my
main things that give us direction is
control the conversation
we're ordering dinner control the
conversation i mean
um
a lot of times people have attended
especially if they're being very passive
or they're really what's happening is
they're being quiet and they're just not
just kind of falling into like a sleepy
place and just kind of getting here it's
like okay here's what's happening
they're saying this i need you to pick
a a position on what they're saying yeah
to you and then control the conversation
every time they want to come back to you
bring it back to you and just
reintuiting or re looking at the lines
through a different lens of going
i understand what you're saying but i
just wanted to interject real quick and
take control of the conversation again
it's always better to give somebody an
action to give them something to do as
opposed to
now be angry yeah well if it's
competently written as well that should
be in the text like if there's
a scene where
that's not there then that's a badly
written scene it's
yes and no because a lot of times i mean
like uh who was it um
story robert mckee says if what we're
talking about is what we're talking
about we're not talking about anything
so the subtext should be there so if
we're talking about ordering dinners
like are we gonna have the chicken
tonight it's really hard to go you
understand what he's saying by that
right it's like well no now we have to
infuse the actual character into that
it's like oh
so we're having chicken tonight
now there's a position that's making
that now i have something that someone
can act off of have you guys seen
the clinician yeah hated it when i first
saw it and it took me being an adult
um much later to go [ __ ] he was
brilliant rahul we're talking about
unforgiven
i just asked them if they've seen it
director of photography is just like
you made me watch it by the way
these two
cameos are your best performances
wow
wow that was a whole monologue the um i
can't believe i'm forgetting the actor's
name the sh the sheriff
you talk about clint eastwood no
plenty to talk about rahul the sheriff
from midnight sheriff in
yeah unforgiveness name's rob
his name is rahul um very advanced i
don't know what his name is it was just
the the performance of that character
who you slowly kind of realize is
technically the bad guy but isn't
explicitly it's very interesting because
he does things that are intimidating
in a way that is not
traditionally intimidating um it was
just a very very interesting performance
to me like
he's intimidating by virtue of sort of
being calm in a situation that isn't
calm and there are so many ways that you
could have played that and so many
choices that he could have made and i
think the one he chose is very very
interesting it had a lot of i love the
notion true power never asserts itself
and to me when people are like they get
louder they get angry um they're
insecure about that they're insecure
about it as opposed to being like i
don't have to flex the line is actually
very quiet the the chuff that a lion
will give can be heard from miles
wasn't it the spartans that would
basically
just stand in total stoic silence in
when facing down like an enemy army they
uh normally you know the armies bang on
their
swords and their spears against the
shield and try to really be this
intimidating force and they would just
stand there and just just
project complete and total discipline
yeah i feel like that was the spartans i
i i could be wrong it was the spartans
and it's um
either way it would work whoever whoever
did it
they had really good torsos though
didn't they that was the gates of fire i
think is a great book that talks about
read that book it's about the
essentially about what the 300 is is
portraying
and and specifically goes far more into
that leonidas and it happened what is it
is it actually a historical event or is
it like mythology
uh spartans the 300 is that that sounds
is it is it real today i mean yeah it's
it's it's a it's all but it's of course
been
heightened
is a novel it's not it's not like a
it's not like a history book
oh okay historical fiction novel that
recounts the battle of thermopylae
but there was the whole thing is that
there were
300 men that stood against the entire
army of yeah um
persians silently silently apparently
with great abs though
every single one of them
i
got some trophies um
for what it's right here
for the communicator awards that i uh
was gonna deliver to you troy and austin
because you also have trophies because
we won an award for communication look
at us go mike you'll get yours when
you're next here okay where are we going
i got a trophy i thought i had got a
trophy i thought i was like no no no
you're not going to get a lot of
trophies but i
one day maybe drive to both of you
austin and troy and drop them off i
figured
drive all the way out to me let's do
that i would like to introduce the same
place i would love to we just finished
our backyard it looks awesome yeah bring
the dog it'll be great
what uh you can bring yours
and also rahul
um
maybe the sheriff we call him
the sheriff
um i yeah we'll still try and do a live
show but again it depends kind of now
when mike is back we we have a venue
that is allowing us to do it
uh we can talk about that a little bit
after we finish recording all right yeah
i'd love to we'll figure it out at some
point they have a lot of flexibility and
they're like excited to
have us go it just when we tried to do
it happened to be um star wars
celebration
the whole week was a bit of a mess
thank you for uh thank you for for um
caring about
the show that i'm in and and
my specific and taking the time to be a
little more focused on me i really do
appreciate it it was so proud of it man
like it yeah it was fanta it was so
[ __ ] good it was one of those things
that like and it doesn't happen to me
very often that i watched it and then i
just sat and thought about it like you
know one of those like it just [ __ ]
sits with you like god it was so good
it was great you were great in it yeah
and it's also that's the thing we've had
a conversation about before uh that i
think it was
mike uh one of my favorite genres of
anything ever and if i could it's a very
good tale if you're a good writer is
things either taking place in just one
place or in one room it's just all that
and it is a lot of episodes man
i have one final question from mike
bithell
yes how was my accent
do you know what do you i i can
genuinely answer that question your
accent was so good that i turned to
kerry when we were watching i was like i
thought this was the troy one but i'm
not sure
and that is i didn't know troy was
british
he's been he's been doing a [ __ ]
troy what was your first question when
you showed up to record video for me
it's like maybe we can do a british
accent with this guy you actually did it
you didn't even ask your like let me
just come all the way to
your credit you're offering me a phrase
to your credit you're like let me just
hear what you want to do with this i was
like i was thinking maybe this i did
that he just went
no british well that happened to me too
when i worked with mike i wanted to do
american and he said no i was like okay
because i'm a much better actor than an
american accent
i uh
much i'm a little like fingers crossed
[ __ ] my kids
i want to hear all the ideas but you
know
but also shut up i will say that women
don't like you if i disagree
um all right thank you for watching
everybody i'm alan i'm a video game
right now yeah spotify listeners that's
austin wintry he's a video game proposal
and that's mike bethel he is video game
director
we got trophies i don't i can't thank
the audience it wasn't voted but thank
you for listening to the show anyway
yeah we appreciate it if you weren't
here presumably we wouldn't have got
them so thank you yeah that's true
nobody would have found the show so
thank you so much
uh we'll see you next time bye